gebeutelte sieger die
ministerpräsidenten von sachsen
brandenburg können wohl weiter regieren
zwei wahlen zwei rekordergebnisse warum
die afg so stark ist und auf dem weg
richtung florida hurricane dorian wütet
auf den bahamas
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den nachrichten vom tag nach zwei
wichtigen landtagswahlen
und auch der sport ist mit von der
partie heute ist norbert lehmann im
studio eine stunde am tag vor mir
selten haben landtagswahlen für so viel
interesse auch im rest der republik
gesorgt wie diesmal
denn in sachsen brandenburg hatte sich
die rechtspopulistische afd aufgemacht
alle anderen parteien zu überholen und
sich an die spitze zu setzen
das ist ihr nicht gelungen wenngleich
sie kräftig zulegen konnte
in sachsen es die cdu von michael
kretschmer stärkste kraft er kann wohl
ministerpräsident bleiben
genau wie dietmar woidke in brandenburg
seine spd schafft knapp platz eins
großer gewinner im osten aber ist die
fdp zahlen jetzt von thomas concia in
sachsen bleibt die cdu stärkste partei
allerdings rutscht sie auf 32,1 prozent
ab größten zuwächse verzeichnet die afd
mit 27,5 prozent verdreifacht sie fasst
er ergebnis wahlverlierer dagegen die
linke die auf 10,4 abstürzt zugelegt
haben die grünen sie kommen auf 8,6 die
spd nun einstellig 7,7 fdp und freie
wähler verpassen den einzug in den
landtag
auch in brandenburg bleibt die partei
des ministerpräsidenten hier die spd
stärkste kraft trotz verlusten
sie erreicht 26,2 prozent und auch hier
ist die afg die zweitstärkste partei mit
23 5 prozent kann sie ihr ergebnis fast
verdoppeln
die cdu fällt auf 15,6 gewinne dagegen
für die grünen 10 acht ihr bestes
ergebnis in einem ostdeutschen
flächenland erst hinter den grünen die
linke wie in sachsen geschrumpft 10,7
das bündnis bvb freie wählerschaft den
einzug in den landtag die fdp wieder
nicht
die große frage jetzt was machen diese
zahlen möglich feststeht neue dreier
bündnisse müssen her
denn eine koalition mit der afg
schließen alle aus in sachsen ist wohl
eine sogenannte kenia koalition am
wahrscheinlichsten also cdu spd und
grüne in brandenburg wäre rot grün rot
möglich
aber auch andere bündnisse mit
beteiligung der cdu sind eine option
es wird also schwierig in den ländern
und das beschäftigt auch die groko in
berlin wie glasboden sack berichtet in
der cdu-zentrale zeigt man sich trotz
schlechter ergebnisse erleichtert um
mögliche diskussionen in der eigenen
partei früher einzufangen bestätigt die
cdu-vorsitzende nochmal die union wird
nicht mit der ard zusammenarbeiten
wir machen politik für alle wählerinnen
und wähler egal ob sie uns ihre stimme
gegeben haben oder nicht aber
gleichzeitig halten wir den kurs der
klaren abgrenzung zur afd
trotz vorbehalten in seinem
landesverband will der sächsische
wahlsieger ein regierungsbündnis unter
einschluss der grünen menschen die eben
wirklich das land in den mittelpunkt
stellen die demokraten sind werden eine
lösung finden
ich bin dazu bereit eine ähnlich
ambivalente stimmung bei der spd die
sozialdemokraten sehen die schuld für
die ergebnisse vor allem in einer
jahrelangen vernachlässigung des ostens
dieses wahlergebnis heißt für alle
demokratischen kräfte das oss themen
stärker ernst genommen werden müssen
forderungen aus teilen der spd die große
koalition als ball zu beenden weiß der
brandenburgische wahlsieger zurück ich
glaube es nervt und und die menschen im
lande dass in der spd immer nach wie vor
über die große koalition gejammert wird
statt wirklich daran zu arbeiten dieses
land voranzubringen
nach den gestrigen wahlen schwant spd
und union das in einer sich verändern
parteienlandschaft vielleicht doch noch
länger zusammenarbeiten müssen als sie
es selber wünschen
schauen wir auf die afd der haben vor
allem männer ihre stimme gegeben und
bürger die vor fünf jahren gar nicht zur
wahl gegangen sind
auch ein blick auf die karte lohnt sich
in brandenburg wählte hauptsächlich der
restliche teil die afd
ein ähnliches bild in sachsen auch hier
gewinnt die afg vor allem die bezirke im
osten des landes darunter
strukturschwache gebiete und regionen
die direkt von kohleausstieg betroffen
sind aber auch städte wie meisen auf die
all das nicht zutrifft aus der region
berichtet steffen moritz lampert walde
bei meißen ein ort mit 2500 einwohnern
mit hübschen häusern bahnhof bus und
supermarkt und doch scheinen die leute
unzufrieden zu sein denn fast jeder
zweite hat hier die afg gewählt einfach
für die heimat einsetzen also wird das
regionale das gefällt mir eigentlich
ganz gut daran hat man jetzt um so das
gefühl also gerade die cdu sie hatten so
lange zeit da jetzt mal zu dem kleinen
mann zu kommen und dann haben die nur
mit anderen süßen sachen zu tun
ich bin eine die wirklich immer arbeiten
geht aber da sind dann ob es ein
mindestlohn und mein mann ist krank und
da geht die post ab september wenigstens
arbeiten geht und dadurch ich habe mich
gegen ausländer aber die kommen und
kriegen ihr geld und alles drum und dran
und ich täglich und drei jahre dass der
eu rente kriegt es kann aber auch nicht
stimmt mit 48 3 prozent hat hier die afg
in sachsen das beste ergebnis
eingefahren
thilo alexe von der sächsischen zeitung
hat die partei von beginn an begleitet
deren wahlerfolg war für ihn
vorhersehbar sie hat relativ rasch
flächendeckend verwende in sachsen
gegründet sie hat
bei mitgliedern schnell zugelegt und
kann eben auch mobilisieren kann man die
leute reingehen hat eine basis die
ebenso arbeitswillig ist das ist der
eine grund und der zweite grund ist dass
es der afg immer wieder gelungen ist so
auch jetzt nicht wieder zu mobilisieren
es ist der faktor angst wut auf denen
die afg gesetzt und damit gepunktet hat
man spricht ja mancher vor den
ostdeutschen ländern als dunkel
deutschland ich bin der auffassung dass
sl deutschland ist die sind ziemlich
helle da und sehr viel sensibler eine
rechtspopulistische partei die sich als
neue kümmererpartei der ostdeutschen
gibt ja und nicht nur kümmerer partei
will die afg seien sie geriert sich ja
auch als neue sogenannte bürgerliche
partei die jetzt immer wieder betont
wird welches signal will die partei denn
damit senden theo koll in berlin
nun ich glaube die afg versucht sich mit
dem begriff bürgerlich vor allem aktuell
in sachsen als koalitionsfähig mit der
cdu zu geben aber vor allem in sachsen
und brandenburg wird wie auch in
thüringen wo dann im oktober gewählt
wird die afg vom erfolg des
nationalistischen flügel dominiert er
wurde anfang des jahres vom
verfassungsschutz als verdachtsfall für
rechtsextreme bestrebungen eingestuft
und ihre anführer sind eher aus dem
radikalen teil der partei andreas
kalbitz beispielsweise spitzenkandidat
der brandenburger fdp und reiner der
chefdenker der partei hat kürzlich
bestätigt dass er an einem marsch von
rechtsextremen athen teilgenommen hatte
wie auch als jüngerer mann an einem
sommerlager eines mittlerweile
verbotenen rechtsextremen vereins also
unter bürgerlich werden die meisten
menschen etwas anderes verstehen
danke bis hierhin theo koll wir sprechen
gleich weiter erst noch ein blick auf
das abschneiden der anderen parteien
da haben die linken die funktion
eingebüßt sie praktisch seit der
wiedervereinigung inne hatten nämlich
protestpartei und sprachrohr vieler
ostdeutscher zu sein
diese rolle hat nun die afg übernommen
die linken sind schockiert und üben
gründlich selbstkritik besser ist die
stimmung bei den grünen die im osten
bisher kaum ein bein
auf die erde bekommen hatten weniger mit
einem blick auf beide parteien
es herrscht katzenjammer bei der linken
die partei hat es nicht mehr geschafft
die hinter sich zu bringen die sich
abgehängt oder benachteiligt fühlen
kümmer partei des ostens das war mal
warum versteht die partei selbst noch
nicht so ganz
es sind mit deutlich besseren prognosen
in den die wahl reingegangen und dann in
einem schlechteren ergebnis ausgegangen
das deutet darauf hin dass wir einfach
strukturelle probleme haben in den
landesverbänden in den landesverbänden
im osten die niederlagen stellen auch
die zukunft der beiden vorsitzenden in
frage wie sie selbst zugeben was uns als
linke jetzt nicht hilft und was den
menschen für und mit denen ihr politik
machen nicht hilft ist wenn wir jetzt so
ein modell reflexhaft display geben also
reflexhafte schuldzuweisungen oder das
modell schlachteplatte fahren sondern
die anklage sagt jetzt nächsten acht
wochen alles zu tun was den wahlkampf in
thüringen unterstützt statt
schlachteplatte kuchen statt
personaldiskussion lehnen die grünen
feiern sich durch robert habeck
fünfzigsten geburtstag plant analysen
auch sie haben nicht ganz so gut
abgeschnitten wie vorhergesagt werden
aber für koalitionen gegen die afg
gebracht nur wenn man mit anpackt kann
man auch verändern und deswegen gehen
wir jetzt natürlich in gesprächen mit
rein
aber das wird ein weiter weg grad in
sachsen auch ein harter weg bei der fdp
soll alles beim alten bleiben keine
kurskorrektur trotz wahlschlappen mehr
bewegung in berlin dürfte es nach der
wahl in thüringen geben inhaltlich wie
personell dann nochmal zu theo koll nach
berlin schauen wir noch auf die folgen
dieser wahlen insgesamt vor allem für
die coco in berlin theo nun ich glaube
der wahlausgang und vor allem der
massive stimmengewinne der afg scheint
bei der groko offensichtlich eine art
turbo eingeschaltet zu haben olaf scholz
hat die latte heute schon sehr hoch
gehängt der sagte die große koalition
brauche jetzt einen großen wurf in der
klimapolitik um als regierung überhaupt
keine berechtigung zu haben und genau
dazu sitzt man jetzt hier hinter mir im
kanzleramt zusammen morgen tagt die
union sogar ganztägig zum thema klima
scholz hat das thema jedenfalls gleich
mit dem fortbestand der koalition
verknüpft und zudem wünschen sich beide
seiten union und spd eine rasche
einigung bei der grundrente möglichst
noch vor der nächsten landtagswahl in
thüringen also es läuft ja ab sofort und
beschleunigt eine art große
dringlichkeit programm namens wähler
rückgewinnung von der afd
vielen dank für einordnung und ausblick
theo koll in berlin unter dem titel hfd
erfolge im osten wie weiter nach den
wahlen sendet das zdf auch ein spezial
direkt im anschluss an diese sendung und
auf heute de finden sie weitere infos zu
den landtagswahlen unter anderem eine
analyse der wahlergebnisse in den
einzelnen wahlkreisen jetzt nach london
dort verliert premierminister boris
johnson für seinen rexit kurs an
rückhalt in den eigenen reihen nach
einer dringlichkeitssitzung des
kabinetts trat er vor wenigen minuten
vor die presse
diana zimmermann in london was hat er
denn gesagt er hat gesagt dass die
wähler und er unbedingt den dreck cit am
31 oktober rollen und da sich
tatsächlich die opposition gerade
anschickt zu versuchen ein gesetz zu
erlassen
das ihn zwingen soll nach brüssel zurück
zu gehen und den wechsel bis zum 31
januar 2020 zu verschieben hat er an die
parlamentarier gerichtet gesagt er wird
auf keinen fall diesen antrag in brüssel
stehen und ohne zu sagen das ist dann zu
parlamentswahlen kommt wird hat er
gesagt er will diese wahl nicht und die
parlamentarier wollten diese wahlen
sicherlich auch nicht alles läuft darauf
hinaus dass wir hier tatsächlich in
dieser woche ein showdown erleben und
boris johnson der schon sein gesamtes
regierungsteam daraufhin ausgerichtet
hat dass es gut in der lage sein wird
warnen zu bestreiten scheint sich einmal
mehr in der position bestärken zu wollen
dass er derjenige ist der den
wählerwillen durchsetzen will das
parlament hindert ihn daran
und deswegen braucht er ein neues
parlament aufregende zeiten in england
vielen dank für diesen kurzfristigen
überblick diana zimmermann nach
kalifornien an der pazifikküste der usa
hat es einen verheerenden brand an bord
eines ausflugsschiffes gegeben
fünf menschen konnten gerettet werden 34
werden noch vermisst
das schiff befand sich vor der
kalifornischen küste nahe der insel
santa cruz einem beliebten ausflugsziel
für taucher und segler als das feuer in
der nacht ausbrach schliefen viele
passagiere unter deck die fünf
geretteten mitglieder der crew hielten
sich offenbar auf dem oberdeck auf der
gegenüberliegenden seite der usa machen
sie sich bereit für einen monstersturm
so bezeichnet präsident tram hurricane
dorian ein der gewaltigsten stürme der
je gemessen wurde
und der gerade kurs auf die ostküste
nimmt und so sieht er aus mit
windgeschwindigkeiten von bis zu 300
kilometern pro stunde hütete er auf den
bahamas
aktuell hat er zwar sich etwas
abgeschwächt bleibt aber gefährlich
florida georgia und north carolina alle
bereiten sich vor auf zerstörerische
winde sturmfluten und jede menge regen
britta jäger dorian trifft die bahamas
mit einer windgeschwindigkeit von mehr
als 300 kilometern pro stunde und wütet
auf der inselgruppe wie kaum ein
hurricane vor meter hohe sturmfluten
drücken wasser in die straßen und häuser
der wind reißt bäume um der materielle
schaden ist enorm
nach den bahamas nimmt der hurricanes
nun kurs auf die usa dort soll er an der
ostküste entlang richtung norden ziehen
wir werden hart daran arbeiten die
auswirkungen dessen zu minimieren was da
kommen wird wir wissen doch nicht mehr
genau was da kommt
noch ist unklar ob und wenn ja wo genau
dorian auf land treffen wird die
betroffenen bundesstaaten sind alarmiert
im south carolina oder hier in florida
laufen überprüfungsmaßnahmen dieser
sturm dieser stärke kann wirklich
massive zerstörung anrichten
wie die aussehen könnte batterien auf
den bahamas bereits gezeigt in berlin
freude über den ersten panda nachwuchs
in deutschland und dann sind das gleich
zwillinge
die babys kamen vorgestern im berliner
zoo zur welt doch lange werden sie nicht
bleiben
nach rund vier jahren gehen sie
voraussichtlich zurück nach china
denn laut vertrag gehört der
pandanachwuchs der volksrepublik die
eltern aber bleiben sie sind noch für 13
jahre ausgeliehen für rund eine million
us dollar pro jahr
das geld fließt nach chinesischen
angaben zurück in die panther zucht ja
und nun zu tier norbert und zum grand
slam turnier in new york und da ist
dominik heraus geschieht ja die große
deutsche us open überraschung als
qualifikant gestartet unterliegt er im
achtelfinale in vier sätzen den russen
dani im bett wird jetzt und der ist
immerhin weltranglisten fünfter der
umjubelte verlierer ging als stiller
sieger beschluss hat bisher auch die
kraft gefehlt nach sechs matches
da kann ich auf jeden fall erhoben des
hauptes wieder heimgehen und ja bin
überglücklich
gegen medwedew oben im bild spielt
köpfer mutig und gewinnt den ersten satz
gegen die nummer fünf der welt mit 6 zu
doch dann holt der russe die nächsten
beiden sätze köpfer wird müde und hat
den tie-break des vierten keine chance
mehr das match ist verloren hoffentlich
war das jetzt also anfang von vielmehr
nächsten monaten und jahren
erst mitte september als einer der
besten 100 der weltrangliste seit 18 uhr
ist es geschlossen das transferfenster
in der fußball-bundesliga zuvor noch
einen last minute tauschgeschäft
zwischen frankfurt und ac mailand
eintrag stürmer ante ribitsch geht dafür
kommt der 23 jährige andré silva an den
main
ja und er wäre gerne auch noch durch
transferfenster geschlüpft bayern
verteidiger jérôme boateng
er bleibt nun doch wohl oder übel in
münchen und wechselt nicht nach turin
angeblich hat juventus in letzter minute
abgefunden morgen das zweite em
qualifikationsspiel für deutschlands
fußball-frauen gegen die ukraine letztes
training der mannschaft heute mittag in
lewis alle sind fit bundestrainerin
martina voss-tecklenburg weiß wie man
gegen die starken osteuropäer gewinnen
kann
der plan ist dass wir natürlich auf
unsere stärken gucken dass wir guten
zugriff haben wollen dass wir permanent
den gegner auch mit unserem tempospiel
vor probleme stellen wollen aber wir
wissen auch dass die ukraine im
umschaltspiel im konterspiel gut ist und
das wollen wir unterbinden
unser spiel morgen live bei uns im zdf
zu sehen ab 15 uhr 45
danke norbert und zum wetter da wird es
für die meisten ein sonniger tag morgen
im norden soll es aber etwas regnen wo
genau das sagt ihm gleich konnte tisch
das war es von uns wir danken für ihr
interesse claus kleber informiert sie
mit dem heute journal um 21.45 und
morgen begrüßt sie an dieser stelle
wieder barbara hellwig wir wünschen noch
einen sonnigen abend und sagen tschüss
[Musik]
und damit die zuschauer die frische luft
bei uns die erwärmt sich morgen ein
bisschen so haben wir dann temperaturen
von gut 20 grad in mitteleuropa aber
dennoch haben eine kühle delle
eingerahmt von der hitze hier am
schwarzen meer und in der ukraine oder
von der wärme über frankreich kälter ist
es dagegen im norden norwegen island und
schottland nur 10 bis 15 grad ja frisch
wird sondern 8 bei uns das sind morgen
früh meist zwischen 5 und 13 grad in den
mittelgebirgen jetzt runter auf zwei
grad und anfangs wird es noch ein
bisschen regnen hier im südöstlichen
bayern das lässt nach und der regen hier
an der nordsee kommt nach mitternacht
und der wind legt dann zu morgen haben
wir dann einen zum teil starken süd ost
wenn dort mit stürmischen böen
südwestwind mit starken böen dazu und
weitere schauer ziehen nach osten über
norddeutschland hinweg im landesinneren
da lockert es mehr und mehr auf und in
der mitte und im süden haben wir
freundliches wetter sonne und wolken zum
teil ist der himmel auch wolkenlos die
temperaturen steigen noch ein bisschen
an gegenüber heute 20 bis 26 grad nur im
norden von schleswig-holstein an der
ostsee bleibt es ein bisschen frischer
und damit woche wurde norddeutschland
wieder nass werden aber sonst wird es
noch mal sonnig und waren donnerstag und
freitag ist es deutlich kühler und
wechselhafter mit schauern und einzelnen
gewittern
ich wünsche ihnen einen schönen abend
und machen sie es gut